Now, let's share this
prototype with someone.
There are three ways to do this.
First, you can select
the Share Link button.
This allows you to generate
a unique URL that anyone can view.
Your project screens can be viewed
on a desktop or mobile device.
Anyone with this link can view, interact
with and comment on your screens.
You can email it, SMS it, embed it or
even download it for offline viewing.
Simply copy and paste this URL,
and send it to your participant.
Second, you can add someone to
your project as a collaborator.
Adding a collaborator to your project
effectively gives them full edit access.
This enables to view, interact with,
comment on the screens, edit and
add and remove screens as well
as edit and add hotspots.
To do this,
simply click on the plus sign in the
upper right of your project home view.
Adding a collaborator will give that
person full access to your project.
Third, you can start
an instant LiveShare event.
A LiveShare meeting enables you to have
a real time collaborative discussion
with anyone with Internet access.
Participants of your meeting can draw,
add comments, and
view your project in a one-time event.
You can have unlimited
participants in your meeting, and
you don't need to book
your meetings in advance.
Plus, you can have as many
LiveShare meetings as you need.
Simply copy and paste this link and
send it to anybody you want to
participate in your meeting.
You can turn on a VoIP call here
where people can join a VoIP, or
you can have them dial into this phone
number for a private conference line.
In the bottom left, you'll see
that there's a group chat window.
Participants can turn
on the drawing tool,
where you can draw over your designs, or
you can turn on a whiteboarding option.
Any of your designs can be
saved to a Snaps folder or
emailed to all of your
participants on the fly.